back to the house right now i'll be back
behind my desk this afternoon
making sure that the decisions about our
next steps out of the covered lockdown
are the right ones
i said in the campaign that is my
priority for as long as it takes to get
us through crisis
and into recovery we published during
the campaign a very ambitious 100 days
programme and we'll start to implement
that immediately
of course once the crisis is over i also
said in this election i wanted to give
people in scotland the choice of
independence and i intend to do that
when we are out
of the crisis so when do you start
pushing for that referendum
well when we judge the time is right
that will not just be a judgment for me
the scottish parliament which of course
now has a majority a bigger majority of
msps in favor of an independent
referendum then was the case
before the election so the parliament
will judge when the time is right i
indicated in our manifesto that if the
covert conditions allow i would like
that to be in the first half of
this parliamentary term but covert comes
first the country
getting through and out of this crisis
comes first when i said that in the
campaign
i meant it and that's why i'm going
straight back to work to continue that
job of getting us through
this situation and in terms of
introducing the legislation
in parliament when could we expect to
see that well again that will
be uh based on the judgment as to when
the time is right we've got
a difficult few months still ahead of us
we're in a good position with covert i
hope everything is going firmly in the
right direction but we've got to make
sure that that
continues to be the case and that we get
on with the job of
delivering that 100 days plan getting a
recovery from covid
underway the legislation if a referendum
is to be delivered within the first half
of this parliament which is my
preference
covert permitting we have to introduce
the legislation in a
time frame to facilitate that happening
but of course these will be decisions
for the whole parliament
once it is back in operation next week
but that time frame suggests it would be
quite soon towards the end of this year
i'm not going to give you a date right
now because that would
not be consistent with what i've said
all the way through this campaign is
that covert comes first and i can't tell
you with certainty right now
when i in the scottish parliament will
judge that we are sufficiently out of
the crisis
to do that but that time frame is the
broad one we put in our manifesto
and obviously legislation would have to
be introduced in a time scale to
facilitate that
do you take reassurance from the words
from the uk government this morning that
they wouldn't be taking the scottish
government to court if it reached that
stage well look if we end up
in court which is not something i want
to see
that would only be because we had a uk
government that refused to accept
scottish democracy
and i think that would be an absurd
outrageous and completely unacceptable
position for them to
be in i support independence the uk
government
oppose independence that's legitimate
but the only people who have the right
to decide that question
are the people of scotland and the way
to do that is in
a referendum so you know it's this
discussion that often dominates
the debate about independence will the
uk government permit a referendum
you know it's predicated on a lack of
basic respect for scottish democracy the
snp
has just won a landslide election
victory on the strength of
a commitment to referendum when the time
is right there is a pro-independence
majority
in the scottish parliament you know the
statistics of this election campaign
in many respects are record-breaking for
the snp so
the question for the uk government is a
simple one and it should not be a
controversial one
do they accept democracy or don't they
and i hope that
however they might couch that at this
stage
they will accept democracy because
anything else is just completely
unacceptable the message from them seems
to be
not never but not now so are you in some
ways
in agreement with them over there you'd
have to ask them that i hope so i am
saying not now because as i've just said
i'm getting back to work to
continue the work to get us through
covet but when we're out of the crisis
then
people in scotland have voted for a
parliament
that says we should have an independence
referendum after the crisis
in order to shape our long-term recovery
and if the uk government has any respect
for scottish democracy which they
haven't
displayed very firmly over the past few
years but if they are prepared now to
accept scottish democracy
it should just be a question of when the
parliament of scotland elected
democratically on thursday
decides that the time is right then
justice happened in 2014 there should be
an agreement between the uk
and the scottish governments i hope that
is what will happen and
that is the situation that would be
consistent with
respect for a democratic outcome the
unionist parties are pointing to the
vote
share being split pretty much down the
middle what are you making of that
argument do you still have a case to
make to a lot of people
look having a referendum does not
automatically mean that scotland becomes
independent scotland will only become
independent if i can
persuade if the snp and the yes movement
can persuade a majority that again is
also a fundamental
principle of democracy but this argument
i mean you've got all these
desperate attempts to rewrite the basic
rules of democracy
you know on the strength of the argument
that the uk government appears to be
rather
desperately making boris johnson
wouldn't have a mandate to do anything
and you know that is the the simple
issue at stake here the s p won the
election we've won the election
with a a set of record-breaking
achievements you know we've got
more votes in the constituency ballot in
this election than any party in the
history
of devolution you'd have to go back i
think to the 1960s to find a uk party
that got
a higher percentage or as higher
percentage of the vote in a uk
general election the mandate is there
the majority in the parliament is there
that doesn't mean scotland automatically
becomes independent but it does mean
that it is for the scottish people
to decide and it strikes me that this
argument scotland's divided and split on
the question of independence
it's not an argument against the
referendum it's an argument for allowing
that to be determined
democratically because otherwise it's
politicians who make that decision and
that is not right
other than the letter from the prime
minister have you spoken to him at all
again
i'm going to speak to him later this
afternoon um you know he wrote to me
yesterday
suggesting a covert recovery summit of
course we'll be delighted to take part
in that and work constructively with
anybody to get us through clovid
and into recovery but longer term i'm
not sure that the kind of recovery that
boris johnson will envisage
is the one that a majority of people in
scotland will support and that brings to
the four this question who is it that
should shape
our long-term recovery and the kind of
country scotland becomes out of that
recovery should it be boris johnson or
should it be the people of scotland